we begin with the coronavirus pandemic
and the discovery of a new variant
called omicron it's seen countries
around the world restricting travel to
and from southern africa
south africa botswana zimbabwe namibia
lesotho and mozambique are among those
affected by the rules
the news has shaken the world economy
just as it was showing signs of her
recovery stocks on wall street took a
hit on friday before they close for the
weekend
and in south africa itself the number of
confirmed omicron cases are still
relatively low but the speed with which
young people are getting sick is causing
alarm
let's cross now to paul brennan who's in
london for us paul news of this variant
is arriving on the scene in europe
which is already seeing big increases
lockdowns as a result of the delta
variant how is this news of this extra
variant on the scene going to go down
with the public
yeah there's serious concern among
politicians and the scientists here um
they are trying to be cautious they
don't want to panic the public and they
certainly don't want to start talking
about reimposing uh really strenuous
lockdowns in those countries where they
have been resistant to lock down so far
um there is a question mark about how
compliant the public will be if the
scientists act quickly and impose
lockdowns before the evidence suggests
those lockdowns are necessary we already
saw last weekend for example
in vienna in croatia in italy big
protests in belgium as well big protests
against the idea of uh vaccine man
mandates and and uh extra lockdowns that
said uh as you mentioned
it's the timing it's the worst possible
timing we knew that the coronavirus
variants would be on surge again during
winter because people in the european
continent gather together it's colder
it's wet
people don't tend to spend that much
time outside they get together in houses
and in inside venues and the delta
variant is still in its kind of fourth
wave here in europe so to add a new
potentially more infectious variant
is the worst possible timing
paul uh
this is something you're not going to be
aware of i'm just hearing it now from my
producer apparently news coming in
on the wires that cases
linked to this new variant have been
discovered now in the uk inc
very worrying indeed
well it was seen that is news uh but i
can tell you that uh it was regarded as
inevitable uh by several of the
scientific experts who've been
interviewed uh on various media outlets
here in the uk over the past 12 to 24
hours basically ever since uh the uh
dutch netherlands uh cases uh were known
about uh it was regarded as inevitable
in today's globalized society with
people flying around and with the
gestation period of the coronavirus
being anything up to 10 days perhaps
even 14 days that
even after you've imposed flight bans on
those southern african countries
somebody might be harboring the virus
not yet being symptomatic and still
arrive in uk shores or in other
countries here in europe and bring the
virus here uh it was yeah it was a
concern uh it was inevitable though so i
don't think that's going to be a massive
surprise the question mark will be now
is what is the response going to be to
its arrival indeed and what more can you
tell us about this uh new variant do we
know much more about how quickly it's
transmitting
well no that and that's one of the
difficulties and it's also one of the
reasons why the scientists are being
somewhat cautious before they start to
say look it's more deadly it's more
infectious they're not quite sure yet
the studies are ongoing
what we do know is that these spikes if
you imagine the coronavirus itself as a
as a ball with these spikes uh coming
off it um it's the mutations on those
spikes and the significant number of
extra mutations that this variant has
which makes it very different to the
other variants that we've seen before i
think it's a more it's 32 mutations that
this particular variant of coronavirus
has
different to the half a dozen that the
other variants have had in the past
and it's the question mark as to whether
those variations those mutations will
mean that the new variant is not going
to be recognized by the vaccines that
have already been put into so many
people's arms will the vaccines work
against this new variant the scientists
just don't know
and without that knowledge it's
difficult to to decide as to how deadly
it will be and how much more infectious
it will be so much more study needs to
be done but it needs to be done really
quickly as the spread
clearly is getting out and around the
world it is indeed paul brennan there
for us in london and just to repeat to
you this news coming in just in the last
few seconds the uk health minister has
said that cases linked trace to the
southern african new variants
have been found in the united kingdom